dans la vie de cramât torse qu'à 25 km
du front alors que le son des tirs
d'artillerie résonnent au loin les
habitants eux se préparent à affronter
l'hiver ils font des réserves en bois
pour chauffer leur maison dans des
poêles fourni par le gouvernement ici la
température peut descendre jusqu'à -10°
nous sommes très inquiet car l'hiver va
être rude
ça ne sera pas agréable
nous allons nous rassembler au même
endroit pour rester au chaud et tout se
passera comme prévu
soixante mille personnes sont restés
vivre a créé amateurs 5 avant la guerre
la ville comptait 220 mille habitants
lient le d'olga 60 ans a récemment été
endommagé par une frappe comme tous les
autres habitants olga vie sans gaz
depuis des mois car la russie a cloué
son approvisionnement le dombass ans
mais je ne m'inquiète pas pour mes
enfants mais pour mes petits enfants
les enfants peuvent mettre des vêtements
chauds et les adultes peuvent se serrer
dans les bras mais pas ses petits bébés
en juillet le président et craignent un
v supplié les habitants de la région de
donetsk d'évacuer obligatoirement mais
beaucoup ici n'ont nulle part où aller
les gens ont perdu leur emploi il n'y a
pas de travail il n'y a pas de
transports publics vous pouvez le voir
alors que vous vous avez un salaire un
retraité n'a qu'une pension d'une
cinquantaine d'euros comment vont-ils
survivre
mardi
des centaines de personnes dans le
besoin attendaient leurs paniers
alimentaires
selon le maire de gramat tort sq les
demandes d'aidé humanitaire explose le
nombre de bénéficiaires augmente chaque
jour un peu plus